I would beat the Pearson opposite me at
a round of golf
ing can you show your swing yeah
[Music]
hi I'm Connor Cody and this is agree to
disagree and today I'm joined by Raheem
Sterling Kyle Walker Harry Kane is the
best trainer in England squad oh he's up
there
I I'm talking as a forward for me yeah I
think there's a lot of good trainers in
here
um
so for me to single impulse I'd probably
say no I I agree everyone trains hard
obviously he's a good player but
I would say is the best yeah does it
agree again yeah yeah because I get what
he means I get I'm so but I just mean
like as I said from a afforded
perspective just details that it does in
his game
um I like to see but what you've said
there I think everybody comes in yeah
and he's finishing a training his neck
level on it like he's finishing and he's
in front of goal in these top you know
what I mean as you said you everyone
comes in we're all preparing the right
way I just like seeing little things he
does that's right he's finished he's got
his finish is meant to be good
I mean is in terms of no matter he could
score five goals you know when someone
scores five goal you get some Striker
don't you then might try and think the
next one no no he never does that he
slaps in the middle no matter what he's
focused any every time he gets a chance
that's always been this yeah especially
since I've known this since like 15.
what about the three of you who's the
best trainer Russ
well yeah I'd say here you're on fire
I'm not saying any other place she
wasn't on fire but he's gonna see me
oh you're you're you're ready
yeah
I think here I'll hear you read up like
you're Sharp
yeah no reason it's nice nice side well
I'd say you're a top trainer I'm lucky
okay yeah yeah you're a bit like Harry
yeah
it's just like it's proper you buy the
book everything's done properly there's
no corners cut
I'm not great
no big debate this Stephen Gerrard is
the best England midfielder of all time
oh oh
don't mind it
not strongly disagreeing I'm disagreeing
okay but I could quite easy go to agree
as well I've got two yeah I've got two
of them and I can't like go against one
in it still you've got to I can't no but
you've got to
I feel bad even disagreeing with that
because he's a much better player than
I've ever been so for me to disagree
with that but don't fit we're not like
midfielders don't you go to whatever you
think
I I agree I agree because there's two of
them I think that they're the best
human poor School
Lampard
all the time
do you think him and Paul scholes
interesting I think there's three of
them I think London I was in there as
well yeah oh yeah yeah I'm not saying
you don't think the years but I think
for them to so are you disagreeing
I'm staying here no you can't okay
go one way he's the best
all-time ever England midfielder I have
to disagree okay the answer does not
stand up for me okay yeah I agree that
there's Freedom do you want to move it
that way then no no I agree you agree
that that is three of them
that's the question we're not agreeing
if there's three best we're saying
Steven Jobs I could just stay here there
no no you've got to pick up so you
either agree the best midfielder ever
yeah with there's three of them
the best Midfield ever not not one of
the best three midfielders ever okay
yeah you disagree yeah yeah because you
said there's lots of these things yeah
yeah okay where would you have gone
we've got there agree front lamp
Phil folden is the most technically
gifted player in the England squad
but what's technically well this is the
I had this debate with I like this but
what's technically gifted technically
gifted is naturally gifted isn't he
okay
who else is up there with him naturally
technically who else is up there as a
technical amazing mounts technically
looks good yeah
but do I think that he's so is he more
technically gifted than Phil no I think
yeah I think bro this is what I'm trying
to say this the word technical when they
say technical I believe mace has
different things that Phil can't do no
like if I'm talking about like I don't
know I don't know how to say on this
spot but if I if you're saying born
naturally gifted Phil but there's
certain things like I don't know a dead
ball situation I would prefer mace to be
on the ball yeah yeah so that's that
word
[Music]
so you agree then you don't strongly
agree because you're just named Mason I
said it what I needed no but I think
it's better than them I think he is the
Stronger Yeah but I'm going technical
like you're saying there's different
technical things like dribbling that's
like dribbling but then ball striking
there'll be different players that's
technically better than Philip yeah not
saying he's not good at it I mean so
that's yeah if we say naturally yeah
yeah okay who's the best technically on
the table Connor Connor oh the diag diag
yeah it was just just a Diagon
oh my gosh
it tastes you know listen I'm telling
you no you didn't see your name when he
was in the Midfield
good what what
I got a minute when you were in the
Midfield back in the day bro you were
running the gap he was running he was
running away I swear and we're talking
about you played with some of the best
plays in the world and he's mentioned
wow no this is next Steven Gerald that
was just on YouTube the next series on
YouTube so that wasn't that wasn't your
title I have no idea she did
I've got no left foot
I would beat the Pearson opposite me at
a round of golf
can you show your swing I only say I
can't it's the hardest thing to hit
I hope that give us a little all right
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
but no I need to try I like it though
who's the best in the squad
H H well I don't know what eBay ages
Harry or is Big H yeah big H is good is
he yeah what about the worst is there
anyone you've played with where it's
it's been bad
trips oh he was horrific
he bought all new clubs and everything
yeah so we've got him to buy clubs he
was terrible he was saying I'm gonna
send them back
no he's gonna use him and then go and
give him the receiver done with these
Ben chilwell has the best haircut in the
England squad
yeah I just picked the name at random
yeah
and I don't know I think it depends I
think Jack's got a good haircut but I
think that's more I don't know I don't
think it's a good Echo but I think it's
it's a jack haircut where all the kids
liking it you know doing them a favor
there Phil thought you were gas going
yeah you know someone would say it's a
good haircut but it's a statement one
Calvin
good other way um
who's actually got a trim that you're
actually like stosy stones is strong
yeah
I like just a simple air because you
know me a lot of places again just
normal but I'd like a simple Echo all
the fancy ones I'm not massively into
can I watch your question have you ever
had another trim over than that no never
you're just the same always yeah it's
never changed ever since it looks well
it's working yeah it's stronger life
yeah keep the Airline Airlines all right
go from there I have a better dress
sense than the Pearson opposite me oh I
love it
thank you I drink I think he dressed
very well yeah
I always say to him I think he dresses
up from the night the night before yeah
he's he's eyeing his clothes I've never
seen someone so presentable at this man
what sort of gear do you wear and what
sort of gear does he wear are you
similar no I think I'm a bit random I
mean I tried to put little things
together but yeah he he's very well
dressed very well kept but I reckon if
I'm saying we're going to like where on
Oscar or so I mean you're going out I
reckon I'm not scared that's the circled
yeah and we're both trying to go go for
the award I reckon I've got him
how could I got him I reckon he'll go
safe I can imagine he goes branded
no big Brands no branded expensive
Brands oh do you know what I mean no but
it's not in your face like I would never
wear
I don't know
Atop The Jack gray they would wear would
never wear it no it would never wear it
yeah I mean
a loud top it could be pink light blue
with designers everywhere that's Jack I
would wear a nice hoodie yeah with maybe
I don't know a small logo or something
on here no he loves that 10 is a trading
day 11 picks yeah oh brought into finch
family
are the biggest buds in the England
squad I'm gonna go for you on this you
obviously know him a bit more on a
personal level now
I'm gonna go for you I would say I
strongly agree but in England squad yeah
probably yeah yeah
who's closer than into
gotta make a decision Lads no I'll say I
strongly agree in English
yeah yeah I think I'm so yeah the meat
since that bigger yeah Reese and Jude
always together always together always
together no but no them to a CR on Camp
them too close to them yeah I'd say as
well so the Mason stuff I'd actually say
not on Camp them two actually they've
got the biggest romance because they
know that's a good one oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah the recent Jude one they are I
think more so recent Duty think about it
because there's a couple more in there
with the Mason deck surely I'm sure as
well in the Euros
Ben White and carbon Felix were doing
movie day every day
lovely day every day there was movie day
yeah so there was just watching films
all the time together yeah I used to
have movie days like how many films you
watch today or three we've done three
movies what together oh I didn't know
that yeah that's interesting though
Peter Crouch's robot is the most iconic
celebration ever
what I agree
iconic and it is
that no because it's just because he was
crouching it wasn't like it was funny
weren't it it wasn't the best dance move
in the world but as you said it's the
word iconic I don't think it was like
the best robot I seen but it was like on
equation yeah iconic yeah what are you
thinking I can't say agree yeah I say
agree have you got any on the top of
your dad which is better
oh it was just out of nowhere bro it
just came out of nowhere and stuff like
a pesky one for England oh yeah everyone
was a good one yeah you probably won't
what did he do it was the thing you were
in it yeah yeah I love it that was a
good one for
I think other people have got stronger
celebrations I think that you know it
because it's grouchy but I wouldn't say
it's iconic I think I'm with him
yeah it's not iconic what about the
Ronaldo's it's iconic
iconic
it was a good celebration at the time
but I don't think it's iconic strongwood
I thought you were stronger than that no
no we've got a conversation
I'm with him no England player can speak
a foreign language
hmm clever fella
um John's got a bit of Spanish
you can't get by him can he yeah just
Spanish
yeah I think just Spanish
um Tammy thick feet can speak Italian
Italian
so there's a few yeah
well Julie's Jude picking up German
I don't know I never do speak
don't sound a bit of Portuguese from
wolves
only a bit though but like weird no I
can't see it I can't speak
I can't speak you can understand weird
yeah the odd weird or the odd word yeah
like the Gap would say weird like me
like and I'd know what you're saying
what's wrong what just a word or the
sentence yeah I wouldn't know the
sentence
it's like so I'm saying the presenters
come out and just say I understand
unfortunately
make an elastics tackle is better than
scoring a goal
foreign
for sprinting all the way back
so no it's a question you made a last
hit challenge or you scored the winning
goal what's what do you think of course
I'd like to score the winning goal do
they say winning goal it says score and
a goal
I've always said
I'd rather assist the winner in a World
Cup than score the winner in a World Cup
yeah
that's just me I'm not you know me and
Scott your mother you think miles of it
but the question was I lost its tackle
yeah I know
right I agree I agree I moved a little
bit I'd like to tackle someone and save
a goal I'm with you yeah I'm with you
yeah rather than score yeah yeah Kyle
Walker is the quickest quickest England
player ever
the only one I can pick up is feel yeah
and that's it and I don't think it feels
as quick as it ever you don't think oh I
think it was he was so quick
quick
remember remember we're not running 100
meters here so it's not 100 meters
football quick so I'm not saying you
could have you could my thing your what
makes you different
people quick and then they slow down
yours the longer you run here
and for me that I don't I don't quite
approach it because when I'm running
that full pill I can actually feel like
the wheels go overlooking I'm really not
tired the longer the distance is is the
quicker yes yes I mean for me abandon
him all the time I tried to laugh on
that but ease I'll go with gray I'll go
I figure I think Theo was up there
definitely
it depends
first over five years just like he says
I'm not catching it but then as I I've
been lending over five yards he was so
quick
I'm talking about this all right when
you say quick what we're saying in a
race like 100 meters what we're talking
about 400 meters
how can we talk about football quick
playing football aren't we I don't think
anyone's quicker than you like football
or even 100 meters right I think you're
being for you thanks as I said because
of that because of that initial it's
come back now he's got a little bit of
credit and yeah no no because of that
initial thing yeah fear will be rapid I
do think I'm talking about to follow it
through
today
David back free kick against Greece is
the most iconic England goal ever
you like the word iconic don't you you
know iconic is like oh my gosh like this
is incredible do you disagree there I
think he's a good goal do I reckon it's
iconic I think gaza's is more iconic
yeah but then you look at Michael Owen
for me against the Argentina yeah like
some good goals up there aren't there
please give it I'll give it yeah I'll
give him
have you gone strongly agree yeah so
you're a little pop and then you won't
come here yeah I just think
it's interesting that you know walks
where is Dolly how he's done it what is
that to do to do it to get this to where
we needed to get to
is Iconic do I think it's the best ever
goal for England no definitely not okay
we said iconic moment like it's iconic
moment yeah is it the most iconic goal
scored you said strongly agree no he's
not not definitely not the most iconic
goal scored I think it's up there with
one of them but not much Argentina
Scotland yeah yeah
about you Ellen and imagine we go when
that ensures his goal gets as the
European final was that an iconic goal
no but for them
like Beckham's waiting uh Owen's
dribbled nobody didn't see the best
goals iconic that's what sticks in your
head yeah the iconic is just like yeah
it's iconic you talk about gold iconics
like the zidane comes over yeah
I agree I agree then I agree
I would make a better manager than the
person opposite me
oh
[Music]
I think it would be better
I don't think my character's really a
manager I think he would be better yeah
I was gonna say I'd actually if I was a
manager yeah I don't think I would be
but I think you'll be the perfect more
of an assistant yeah yeah you know get
the lads on the side be the bridge yeah
and it runs a little bit down and if you
put your arm around him you know make
sure that he's the one that I'd say
would rally everyone up yeah yeah I can
see it yes I think manager he would be
better also a manager would you be
terrible
what would you wear what would I wear I
tried to I try to I'll try a little
thing on the top on the side lane yeah
yeah not nothing crazy but I do say you
know I mean right it looks good but I
think I don't think I'd be there I don't
think I'd be the best manager but
I reckon I'd have some I reckon I have
some Tactics still a couple of times
yeah I reckon but the I don't know if
I'd be able to I think you demand
respect no no I don't mean not demand it
but I think just with who you are and
what you do I think you're naturally
demand responsible people respect you
yeah I think people that's what would be
yeah yeah as a manager yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah because what you've done
anything whatever though
yeah but I do believe
not the not the face not to be in the
face of the manager but like behind the
closed doors like I reckon I've got a
little yeah
but not something yeah
how do you stack up a it's a base two as
a manager do you think yeah yeah 100
what's that Khan's got to be a manager
I've even wanted to he's gonna be like
the leading host of a flipping on a sky
or something
I like them both I like them both I like
doing both I'm doing my badges now so
we'll take over from going over for sure
I do you think corner will make a top
manager nice nice one no you would I
enjoy it yeah the whale cover is the
best tournament in all of sports
nothing beats it does it Nothing
Compares you like golf do they need the
golf compare
yeah
love it okay so what other tournaments
would you guys watch outside of football
is there anything that you think
compares I don't think anything compares
I like Wimbledon yeah I went to
Wimbledon
did you yeah this year imagine that yeah
it was okay was it it was okay it was
good but it wasn't
what what matches watch the down did you
yeah
I wanted to go to the toilet and I
couldn't leave to go to the toilet
because you can't leave until they've
finished like they've done a changeover
I was like well
me I'm dying for a week I just want to
go to the toilet but then I didn't
really get it there obviously I did get
it because you couldn't be
no like loud but then when I go outside
for the toilet I had to wait until they
changed over yeah for me to then go back
to my seat so yeah start rooming yeah
yeah it's like it's like proper like you
can't just get up and say I'm going
toilet you've got to wait until people
change so then you go Tyler okay you
want to come back to your city you can't
get up to your seat because they need to
then change again so everyone's just
queuing outside waiting till they get to
the seat
so I think that's the main reason why
you prefer the World Cup
I've just got one more bears but I'm
going to ask this one yeah
has been a brilliant presenter today
that is poor man I think it's been very
good we wear together me and Kyle you
know it was probably not loud do you
write yourself Connor do you think
you've got a career in this I enjoy it
yeah I enjoy letting so people can have
a little pop against each other and I'll
sit back and enjoy it yeah enjoy it yeah
so let me finish if anyone wants to take
him on board
we can do some percentages and work from
there yeah cheers
thank you foreign
looking up to and like you know think of
the history and the people that have had
their hands on it or the the games that
we've watched together with me as a kid